to get a better understanding of
quantitative easing in the american
context especially the context that ben
bernanke is talking about i want to read
this quote from a speech that ben
bernanke gave at the london school of
economics on january 13 2009 so this is
shortly after a lot of the craziness of
the financial crisis was happening but
it was still going on so he's saying our
our approach which could be described as
credit easing
resembles quantitative easing in one
respect so he's saying it's not quite
quantitative easing although it really
is it involves an expansion it involves
an expansion of the central bank's
balance sheet so just to understand what
he's talking about the central bank
it has liabilities and assets like any
corporation and they have to the
liabilities
plus the equity has to match up to the
assets but just for simplicity let's
just have the assets
and the liabilities lining up together
so let's say that this is the central
bank's balance sheet right over here
this is their current assets
and let's say that this is their
liabilities over here so liabilities and
then this is their equity although the
federals the federal reserve's equity is
a little bit strange it's not like
traditional equity that they get to get
all the excess profits and all of that
all the excess profits actually go to
the u.s government
but when the fed prints money what they
literally do is that they create
offsetting liabilities and assets so
when they print money they'll so
literally let's say that they're
printing some money right over here
so that's money that they're printing so
this is literally you could there would
be federal reserve notes being created
so these are notes which are essentially
dollar bills so these are dollar bills
right here being printed either
physically or electronically and then
they have an offsite setting liability
which is just notes outstanding which
just literally saying that hey these are
notes that we've created
notes
outstanding
is the other side of the balance sheet
so just to parse this statement when he
says credit easing it resembles
quantitative easing in one respect it
involves an expansion of the central
bank's balance sheet so this is the
expansion of the central bank's balance
sheet which is essentially the same
thing as printing money and then the
federal bank will get these notes into
circulation by going out into the market
and buying assets
traditionally when the fed is more
focused on short-term interest rates on
overnight borrowing rates between banks
it will use these to buy shorter term
debt that increases the amount of
currency out there the amount of dollars
out there and so it'll lower the
interest rate for people buying and
selling dollars or i should say
borrowing and lending dollars not buying
and selling borrowing and lending
dollars the overnight rate for banks
will go down because there's more
dollars out there the cost of borrowing
them will go down and that's normally
what the fed is concerned about and
they're saying look quantitative easing
is just this idea of expanding that
balance sheet
let's keep reading however in a pure
quantitative easing regime the focus of
policy is the quantity of bank reserves
which are liabilities of the central
bank the composition of loans and
securities on the asset side of the
central bank's balance sheet is
incidental so he's saying in traditional
quantitative easing the central bank
says look i just care about printing
money i just care about printing money
so their their liabilities
increase accordingly so this is notes
outstanding again notes outstanding
again
and the height here is proportional to
how much money they print so maybe this
is another trillion dollars they're
printing but what the federal reserve
saying is in traditional quantitative
easing all the central bank cares about
is get printing this money and getting
it out there into circulation and they
don't really care what their what
they're using this money for so whenever
they get this money in circulation they
do go out there and they do go buy
assets usually treasury assets and then
they say even indeed although the bank
of japan's policy so he's talk he's
comparing relative to what japan did
when they kind of faced a deflationary
crisis
indeed although the bank of japan's
policy approach during quantitative
easing during the quantitative easing
period was quite multifaceted the
overall stance of its policy was gauged
primarily in terms of its target for
bank reserves so you're saying look when
the japanese were trying to fight a
deflationary bank crisis they kept
printing money so they kept increasing
the the liability side of their balance
sheet they kept printing money and they
did use this money for a bunch of stuff
they did use those that money to go buy
a bunch of assets
but their their focus of their
intervention was just how much did they
print they didn't really care they
didn't really engineer where that money
went to they really weren't trying to
change what happens in the markets that
they were participating in
let's keep reading what the fed is
saying in contrast the federal reserve's
credit easing approach focuses on the
mix of loans and securities that it
holds and on how this composition of
assets affects credit conditions for
households and businesses
so what he's saying is is that
we are mechanically doing the same thing
that japan did we're increasing we're
increasing our balance sheet which is
analogous to printing money and we are
also buying a bunch of stuff just like
japan did japan had a multi-faceted
approach that's how they put the money
into circulation but what bernanke is
saying is that our approach isn't just
focused on the amount of of cash that we
are printing our focus is where are we
putting that cash to work where how are
we how can we use this cash that we've
printed to
kind of provide liquidity to ease up
things in certain parts of the economy
to understand what he's talking about
let me draw a yield curve right over
here
let me draw
this yield curve right over here so this
is
this is maturity
on the horizontal axis and this is yield
and i'm going to draw the yield curve
for treasuries so let's say the short
term overnight borrowing for well let's
say let's do the yield curve for
treasuries maybe it looks maybe it looks
something like this so short term
interest rates are already are already
pretty darn close to zero and maybe you
know this is some i don't know what
percentage this is maybe this is like
four percent or something it's not
accurate but just gives you an idea so
this is the treasury yield curve
this is the treasury yield curve now you
could also have a yield curve for other
types of for other types of debt maybe
you have triple a corporate debt so very
safe corporate debt or perceived safe
corporate debt but it's not quite as
safe as u.s treasuries so maybe that its
yield curve might look something like
this
maybe its yield curve looks something
like this
and this difference for any maturity so
maybe this is a 10-year this is 10-year
debt right here this difference between
this aaa
this triple-a corporate debt and the
treasury that is the yield spread and
maybe the the the fed is able to buy
through interventions at first they're
able to print money normally they buy
shorter term debt but maybe they start
buying longer term treasury debt maybe
they buy longer term treasury debt and
maybe that helps get the yield curve for
longer term treasuries down a little bit
helps bring it down but maybe the aaa
corporate debts don't react maybe the
spread doesn't stay constant maybe the
spread
maybe the spread widens maybe the same
thing for other types of debt maybe this
is this is highly rated mortgage-backed
securities maybe they have a slightly
higher
interest rate and once again even though
the treasury interest rates are coming
down while they're intervening because
of all the craziness that's happening in
the economy the spread between
treasuries
and tr and triple a mortgage-backed
securities or the spread between
treasuries and aaa corporate debt
that widens or is another way to think
about it the treasury interest rates are
coming down while these things aren't
following it
so what
ben bernanke is saying is like look we
are doing quantitative easing that we
are printing money and we are using that
money to go buy things in the economy
and we're increasing the amount of cash
that there is in the economy but our
point isn't to increase the amount of
reserves or increase the amount of cash
because it's really not changing the
behavior of banks what we are going to
do is go by things like
highly rated mortgage-backed securities
or things like
like commercial paper aaa corporate debt
so that those things so that those
things the interest on those things goes
down obviously if someone's willing to
pay more for a certain amount of debt
and i've gone over this in another video
maybe it's not so obvious then the
interest rates on it will go down and so
what they're doing is the what bernanke
is saying is he cares more about what
ends up on the asset side of the fed's
balance sheet because it takes these
dollars that it prints and goes buys
other stuff and it wants to put some
mortgage-backed securities over here it
wants to put some aaa corporate debt
over here and maybe it also does some
longer term treasury securities or
whatever else